So, you're ready.
You're eager to get started, and
you can't wait, and you've got nothing.
Nada.
Zilch.
Zippo.
I mean, this is your first app.
It has to be amazing.
Right?
I mean yes and no.
I mean,
your first app is going to be amazing,
obviously because you're building it.
But it doesn't have to change the world.
It doesn't have to be some
groundbreaking thing.
Take that pressure off yourself and
keep some of these key principals
in mind when you're brainstorming?
For one, what I just said.
Your first app doesn't
have to change the world.
You don't have to think of
some revolutionary amazing
thing that's going to feed children and
be awesome.
Just don't worry about it.
Two, find your motivation.
Find something you're passionate about
and you actually want to work on,
because that's going to make
the process much, much, much easier.
Otherwise if you're working on
something that you're not so
into, you might just stop halfway
through because why continue?
Then, keep it simple stupid.
The simple kiss method.
Don't think about a ton of features and
try to conclude everything,
because your just going to
probably end up with a clunky app
that nobody's going to be using.
Then don't worry if your
idea already exists.
That actually just means that
there's a market for it and
you know people want to use it.
Most importantly,
this is your first app, not your last.
So, if it's not your
crowning achievement,
that's okay, because there are many iOS
apps that you will build in the future.
Now, you're going to move forward and
start brainstorming some ideas for
your app.
Now I would recommend that you
always keep a piece of paper, or
your phone, or
some note taking app handy,
because you never know when
inspiration might strike.
Let's go think up some ideas.